[Music]
tranquility
the jungle
[Music]
the trees
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
in the jungle
in this war he played a very
fundamental role that was to provide shelter
to us as  guerrilla to be able to
survive
because in these 53 years of struggle
the trees were right in the bombardments they
protected them when there were no trenches
the best shelter will save her the best
variety of us
as a birth she
has been our friend she has been our
friend in that yes without a doubt it has been  the one
that has given us
[Music]
the relationship of launching with us as the
farc and the environment was brotherhood
[Music]
because we as guerrillas
benefit the environment because
we explained to the peasant the
importance of the forests of taking care of the
forests
I think we have  tried to maintain a
fraternal relationship with nature
because they are three giant mountain ranges
that have served us to carry out
the guerrilla warfare that is the
resistance  to bread, which is a
fair resistance,
mama laguerre, good, bad,
war is never good,
worrisome, the threats that hang
over the environment after this
agreement, there are many regions where
we have always been, so
those territories remain totally
vulnerable, we generate
protection for  those ecosystems because
we
agreed with the communities on what was going
to be the management of their resources that
were in the region where we and
historically we have had a dicta presence.
They are going to take advantage of this to try to
exploit it, for this reason, together with the
communities, we have to design a plan
for that care. Right, they say now,
yes, the valves are gone, we are going
to get the most out of this land, it is very
worrying because the government really
does not  She is interested in the environment,
the only witness saves her is
because she did not experience it there  and all that
happened in that scenario of violence
[Music] well
war is something that should not
exist it is not true
why
here in colombia we are
among colombians among the manu what we
are fighting
so something very hard and that leaves a lot of
a lot of sadness a lot like that to a certain one
because not in war you lose a lot of
people who love
then
[Music]